The fellow scholars hold onto your papers because we have an emergency
situation.
Everybody can make defects now by recording a voice sample such as this one and
the lips of the target subject will move as if they themselves were saying this
not bad, huh?
And now let's see what else this new method can do. First.
Let's watch this short clip of a speech and make sure to pay attention to the
fact that the louder voice is the English translator. And if you pay attention,
you can hear the chancellor's original voice in the background, too. Work.
For our future corporation. I nerd
only eight months ago you were awarded the part.
So what is the problem here? Strictly speaking, there is no problem here.
This is just the way the speech was recorded. However,
what if we could recreate this video in a way that the chancellor's lips would
be sinked, not to her own voice, but to the voice of the English interpreter.
This would give an impression as if the speech was given in English and the
video content would follow what we hear now.
That sounds like something straight out of a science fiction movie,
perhaps even with today's advanced machine learning techniques,
but let's see if it's possible.
This is a state of the art technique from last year that attempts to perform
this.
Um, development and a very different history.
We signed this on the 50th sixth anniversary of the LSA treaty of
1960.
Mm. There are extraneous lip movements,
which are the remnants of the original video so much so that she seems to be
giving two speeches at the same time, not too convincing.
So is this not possible to pull off well now hold onto
your papers and let's see how this new paper does at the same problem in.
Germany, but also for a starting point of a very different, um,
development and a very different history.
We signed this on the 50th sixth anniversary of the Elysee treaty of 19.
Wow. Now that's significantly better.
The remnants of the previous speech are still there, but the footage is much,
much more convincing.
What's even better is that the previous technique was published just one year
ago by the same research group, such a great leap in just one year.
My goodness. So apparently this is possible,
but I would like to see another example just to make sure.
Well, he'd like to on the first issue,
it's not for me to comment on the visits of Madame.
Checkmark so far, this is an amazing leap, but believe it or not,
this is just one of the easier applications of the new model.
So let's see what else it can do. For instance,
many of us are sitting at home yearning for some learning materials,
but the vast majority of these were recorded in only one language.
What if we could read up famous lectures into many other languages, it'd.
Be their computer of his [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Look at that.
Any lecture could be available in any language and look as if they were
originally recorded in these foreign languages.
As long as someone says the words,
which can also be kind of automated through speech synthesis these days.
So it clearly works on real characters,
but are you thinking what I am thinking? Three.
What about lip-syncing animated characters?
Imagine if a line has to be changed in a Disney movie,
can we synthesize new video footage without calling in the animators for yet
another all-nighter let's give it a try. I'll go around.
Wait for my call. Indeed. We can loving it.
Let's do one more for,
of course we have a lot of these meme gifs on the internet.
What about redoubling those with an arbitrary line of our choice?
Yup. That is indeed also possible. Well done.
And imagine that this is such a leap.
Just one more work down the line from the 2019 paper.
I can only imagine what results we will see. One more paper down the line.
It not only does what it does better,
but it can also be applied to a multitude of problems. What a time to be alive.
When we look under the hood,
we see that the two key components that enable this wizardry or here and here.
So what does this mean? Exactly?
It means that we jointly improve the quality of the lip sinking and the visual
quality of the video.
These two modules curate the results offered by the main generator and neural
network and reject solutions that don't have enough detail or don't
match the speech that we hear and thereby they steer it towards much higher
quality solutions.
If we continue this training process for 29 hours for the lip sing
discriminator, we get these incredible results.
Now let's have a quick look at the user study and humans appeared to
almost never prefer the older method compared to this one.
I tend to agree if you consider these forgeries to be defects,
then there you go.
Useful defects that can potentially help people around the world,
stranded at home to study and improve themselves.
Imagine what good this could do well done.
This episode has been supported by Lambda GPU cloud.
If you're looking for inexpensive cloud GPU's for AI,
check out Lambda GPU cloud,
they recently launched Quadro RTX 6,000 RTX,
8,000 and V 100 instances and hold onto your papers
because Lambda GPU cloud can cost less than half of AWS
and Azure.
Plus they are the only cloud service with 48 gigabyte RDX,
eight thousands joined researchers at organizations like apple, MIT,
and Caltech in using Lambda cloud instances, workstations or servers,
make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today.
Our thanks to Lambda for their longstanding support and for helping us make
better videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.